the pillar and ground of the truth for this
purpose the son of god was manifested that he
might destroy the works of the devil and i told
her say that verse meditate on it think about
it fall asleep thinking about that verse i gave
her revelation 12 79 and there was war in heaven
michael and his angels fought against the dragon
and the dragon fought and his angels and prevailed
not neither was the place found anymore in heaven
and the great dragon was cast out that old serpent
called the devil and satan which deceiveth
the whole world he was cast out into the earth
and his angels were cast out with him and i gave
her that verse to uh to read meditate on i gave
a hebrews 2 14. for as much then as the children
are partakers of flesh and blood he also himself
likewise took part of the same that through death
he might destroy him that had the power of death
that is the devil and so she went and apparently
she did what was suggested to her she came back
the next day she said i slept
for the first time in months
and that wasn't the first time i've had other
cases where people couldn't sleep because they
were being disturbed by unseen forces and
all i could do was give them the word of god
plus recommitment of the life the word of god
is not an atm you go get what you want and then
you put it aside the life must be committed to
god fully so that christ can claim that life
as his own and so i'm saying all of this to tell
you at night let the last thing on your mind be
the word of god and if your spouse
says something to you if you're married
listen very curiously and after you've
listened then say the word of god again
are you with me all right god is good
and all the time who is with us now
for the first time you haven't been here so far
this weekend first time where are you from where
is that in this area southern california what city
all right okay don't know where that is but sounds
like a nice place thanks for coming anyone else
yes aha yes yes yes i have some friends from
southern california well announce yourselves
that's right dennis and joey delote and my
good brother next to them where are the others
no they're coming all right anyone else
with us for the first time anyone else
yes my brother where are you from fresno
oh you're from right here okay good to have
you what church are you from who selma selma
bilingual is that what you said all right god
bless selma bilingual any other visitor for the
first time yes sister where you from fresno yes
did you raise your hand oh okay i thought you
did are there any non-seventh-day adventists
with us you're not a seventh-day adventist
you're visiting any non-seventh-day adventists
all right okay before i begin my subject
is the pillar and ground of the truth
if you have one of these would
you accommodate me please
and turn it off i am doing the same
thing mine is off it is quite dead
second favor pray for me while i speak and
simply ask god to put his words in my mouth
it's essential that you do that when peter
stood on the day of pentecost the bible says
in acts 2 14 then peter's standing up with the
11. somehow it was obvious to the listeners that
all the other eleven men were with peter
in this message even though he alone spoke
and there's no surprise in verse 37 the bible
says now when they heard this they were pricked
in their hearts and said unto peter and to
the rest of the apostles men and brethren what
shall we do and so i regard you as the eleven
with whom i stand this morning please ask god
to put his words in my mouth and faith
number three i'd like you to think very
hard as you listen to the word of god
please think let us borrow heads and pray
our father in heaven we thank you today god
for life we thank you father we can come to
you right into your throne room even more than
that we can sit at your right hand through jesus
this is access that not even angels have as we
bow before you holy father look upon us with favor
and mercy grant to us your spirit jesus said
in john 16 13 how be it when he the spirit of
truth is come he will guide you into all
truth guide us there god into truth or we
will surely guide ourselves into error and so i
pray father your angels that excel in strength
would surround this place that we your denominated
people may worship in security and safety
if the others on their way bring them safely their
god hasten their steps use me as an instrument
dear god that your name may be glorified and your
people blessed i pray in jesus name let us all say
amen and amen the pillar and ground of the truth
let's go to a genesis 1 we shall read from verse 1
of genesis 1. i read from the king james version
of the bible genesis 1 reading from verse one
the bible says in the beginning god
created the heaven and the earth
and the earth was without form and void
and darkness was upon the face of the deep
and the spirit of god moved upon the face of
the waters now read verse 3 with me and god said
let there be light and there was light
let me pause is that sister one of us
she's not the lady throwing snowballs all right
now the reason why i asked i'm very
serious about things like this you see
the holy spirit works when we're all one
acts two verse one and when the day of pentecost
was fully come they were all with one accord what
are the next few words are there any seventh
adventists in this audience we're in one place
and so i take this sort of thing very seriously
i was at a church i'll get back to genesis 1. i
won't say where and i sit in the pulpit to preach
i look through the window i saw some children
playing in the parking lot and so i paused and
i said are those our children they said yes
i said are the parents seated before me
yes
would someone go get them and i waited until they
came i was at another church i won't say where
i got up to preach and i said is everyone
present who came to church for service
they said no i said what do you mean no they
said there's a choir rehearsing in the basement
i said during divine service they said yes i
said let's sing a hymn while two fearless deacons
go downstairs and tell that choir come upstairs
the deacons went they came i preached
a few weeks later i got an email from
the choir leader wanting to know why
i asked the choir to come upstairs
i wrote him back very nicely and a friend of
mine who read my email said i'm glad you're
the one who wrote him and not me because if
i had written him to explain why you told
the choir come up it would have been a very
harsh response i'm saying this because we
we are losing respect for
god it bothers me greatly
the way we behave in church where we conduct
ourselves we just are losing respect for god
and god is merciful yes but there comes
a time when god says i've had enough
god may kill you
did he kill azer well let me take back the word
kill he may just withdraw his breath of life
do not play with god the bible says of moses
and so terrible as a sight that moses said i
exceeding fear and quaked when god came down
on sinai moses said my knees were knocking
we have a casual approach to god ah god is
my buddy i heard a noise i shouldn't hear
uh you know god is my friend we
sit back together we discuss the
playoffs and we you know we drink a
six pack of salt you look no no no no
god is the god of heaven and earth when the
angels come into his presence what do they do
they fill their faces and who
am i to come into god's presence
respect god
that's why i wanted to know if that nice lady
was one of us because i would have
sent someone to tell her come inside
all right let's go back to genesis verse
3 of chapter 1 the bible says and god said
let there be light and there was light
the words let there be light
we're reading now microscopically
were those words a suggestion
were they a request
let's read psalm 33 verses 6 and 9 our
subject the pillar and ground of truth
you should know this passage without looking
by the word of the lord where the heavens made
and all the hosts of them by the breath of his
mouth read verse 9 with me now for he spake
and it was done he commanded and it's
so fast the bible says god commanded
now listen to genesis 1 verse 3 and god said
let there be light quiz question for you
let there be light was a what a command
now how do we know that more conclusively
let's go to second corinthians
chapter four we'll read verse 6
our subject the pillar and ground of the truth
second corinthians chapter 4 reading verse 6.
do you have that read with me for god who did
what commanded the light to shine out of darkness
has shined in our hearts stop the
bible says god issued a command
and the light came
let there be light look at verse 6 of genesis 1.
and god said let there be a firmament
in the midst of the waters and let it
divide the waters from the waters what was
that now speak with confidence a command
look at verse 9 and god said let the waters under
the heavens be gathered together unto one place
and let the dry land appear what was
that a command we need not go down
the entire chapter one we can draw a conclusion
creation was the result of what command
ellen white writes in a believer's
patriarchs and prophets page 38 paragraph two
god is the life giver from the beginning
all his laws were ordained to life
god's laws god's commands preserve life
god gives life god's commands preserve life
great controversy page 467 paragraph four ella
white writes the law reveals to man his sins
but provides no remedy while it promises
life to the obedient it declares that
death if the portion of the transgressor
there is a connection between command and life
and i want us to get this connection today
very clearly because too many of us see
god's commands as tedious we do not make
the connection between god's law and life
let's go to genesis 2.
genesis 2 we'll read verses 16 17.
the bible says and the lord god did what commanded
the man saying of every tree of the garden
thou must freely eat but of the tree of the
knowledge of good and evil thou shalt not
eat of it for in the death thou eaters thereof
thou shalt surely die now god introduces to adam
a test which ellen white declares was
the smallest test god could devise
i think she says that in child guidance page 79
paragraph five the smallest test god could devise
the test was of all the trees on the earth in
the garden not just the garden but on the earth
because adam had dominion over how
much of the earth the whole earth
he can eat anywhere he wanted all
of them are yours except this one
don't eat fruit if you eat from it
you'll die so god said don't eat
was that a command yes or no yes
why did the death penalty come
what is disobedience transgression
of a command now follow my logic
and i hope it stands on secure legs if
disobedience to a command results in death
turn that coin around what is the result
of compliance with god's command life
life both physical and spiritual
and so creation was made by command
command is associated with life creation
is to be remembered by sabbath observance
am i right then the sabbath is a reminder that
there is a connection between life and obedience
in a world in which churches preach there's no law
god is too loving to punish the transgressor
do as you like and just go to church there
needs to be a people who lifts up the
teaching of obedience to god's commands
you see the question isn't whether i should
obey the question is obey by what power because
god's commands are divine requirements they're
not secular or earthly let me say that again
they are divine and for a human entity to observe
a divine command that person needs divine power
are you with me thou shalt not kill is not an
earthly command it is divine and no unaided human
can keep a divine command and so the issue isn't
should i obey yes we should obey the question
is by what power by the power of the indwelling
christ the very person who created by command is
the very person who indwells us and enables us to
live in obedience to his commands can you say amen
the sabbath the sabbath reminds us of the
connection between life and obedience but
it's so clear in genesis 2 16 17 verse 31 of
chapter one says and god saw everything that he
had made and behold it was what very good in other
words adam and eve were placed in an environment
that had everything they needed that's the way
god functions by the way let me digress slightly
god doesn't bring you to a desert and then
figure out how am i going to take care of him
remember john 6 the feeding of the 5000
the bible says when jesus then lift up his eyes
and saw a great company come unto him he saith
unto philip verse 5 of john 6 when shall we buy
bread that these may eat and this he said to prove
him for he himself what knew what he would do you
serve a god that has the answer to your problem
before the problem struck
the red sea was a problem for the
israelites not god somebody say amen for god
first corinthians 10 13 they
have no temptation taken you
but such as is common to man but god
is faithful who will not suffer you
to be tempted above that you're able but will
with the temptation also make a way of escape
that you may be able to bear it the bible
says with every difficulty comes a way out
and so when you're in difficulty don't keep
your eye on the difficulty look for the way out
the difficulty is visible the way out is
invisible it is seen only by the eye of faith
but god has guaranteed whatever even
if you brought the problem on yourself
there's a way out you may emerge
with scratches and bruises
but there's a way out and so god
put them in a perfect environment
and god said adam essentially god said
look if you want to preserve this life
if you want to continue to live in a
sinless environment without disease without
crime without plagues without ebola
without war
do one thing what's that come on what's that
in other words adam obedience is the
means of preserving what i have provided
today is god's holy sabbath day
we must remember that the god who created created
by command but there is something else about the
command of god let there be light let's go
to psalm 111 we shall read verses 7 and 8.
1 11 7 and 8 are subject
to pill and ground of truth
are you thinking two people said yes are you
thinking all right what book did i say what
chapter what verses the works of his hands are
what verity and judgment what does verity mean
truth the works of his hands a verity and judgment
all his commandments are sure they stand fast
forever and ever and are done how in truth and
uprightness what are the works of god's hands
psalm 8 3 when i consider thy heavens the works
of thy fingers the moon and the stars which thou
hast stood in that is part of the works of
god's hands i say part of it listen to the
father speaking to the son hebrews 1 10 and thou
lord at the beginning hath laid the foundation
of the earth and the heavens finished the
verse for me are the works of thy hands
the works of his hands are
verity and judgment truth
i want you to think clearly with me
as i try to put this point across
our subject the pill and ground of truth
the bible says of god god is not a man
that he shall lie neither the son of
man that he should repent hath he said
and shall he not do it or have he spoken and shall
he not make it good now the verse is saying god
does not lie why is it god does not lie reasons
given in the verse whatever he says finish my
words happens whatever he speaks stands fast now
if that's the opposite to lie what is that truth
there are two ways to lie
deliberately twisting the truth or making a
statement and finding yourself confronted with
circumstances that make it impossible
for you to live up to what you said
you missed it and it's my fault
you didn't have to agree so
enthusiastically listen carefully
there are two ways to lie one
deliberately falsifying the
truth that was someone says to you how old
are you you say 35 when you're really 55.
that's one way to lie deliberate falsification the
other way is to make a statement of intention and
be unable to follow through are you with me
now that's not as a moral lie but that is a
situation where intent and outcome do not match i
get the impression i'm losing you am i losing you
a lot of us we intend but the intention and
the outcome they don't match in other words
i will come to secrets and sealed uh meeting this
weekend bought the ticket and then my father died
can't come intended the outcome did not match
the intent are you with me that's not truth
now it's not a moral lie it is inconsistency
now the bible says that can't happen to god
god doesn't lie morally and god cannot
find himself in a circumstance where
what he says doesn't happen because
there was a flood or an earthquake
you haven't gotten it yet i'm not
convinced you are let me put it this way
i uh was scheduled to be here 7 45 and i was
here 7 30. what if i had fallen in the shower
hit my head knocked out i wouldn't be here
and you'd be wondering why did they invite
that man he can't keep time because we never
assumed the best you see we assumed the worst
my intention would have been to be here am i clear
the outcome was different that's inconsistency
what i'm saying to you if god
says i'm coming to your side
no sleeping in the shower can stop god are
you listening to me now god is not a man that
he should lie neither the son of man that he
should repent hath he said what is that intent
and shall he not do it what's that outcome or hath
he spoken what's that intent come on speak to me
what's that and shall he not make it good what's
that outcome now listen to god let there be light
what if light hadn't come
what if light had not come would have been a lie
not necessarily a moral lie but there would have
been no consistency between intent and outcome
so when god said let there be light and there was
light number says hath he said and shall he not
do it or hath he spoken and shall he not make it
good when god said lay there be light it was made
good because the light came that's a form of truth
are you following me now listen to psalm 111
verse 7 the works of his hands are verity and
judgment all his commandments are sure they stand
fast forever and ever and are done how in truth
the bible says all god's commandments are truth
creation was by command creation also truth
what god says happens
it's no surprise the bible says thy law is
the truth all thy commandments are truth
we discovered yesterday in the morning the sabbath
is a reminder that we are accountable to god
do you remember that the sabbath is a reminder
that for every person there is a purpose because
creation has purpose design there's a reason
for everything and i gave you a lovely quotation
from ellen white desire veggies page 20 paragraph
2 there is nothing save the selfish heart of man
that lives into itself no bird that cleaves
the air no animal that moves upon the ground
but ministers to some other life there is no leaf
of the forest or lowly blade of grass but has
its ministry every tree and shrub and leaf pours
forth that element of life without which neither
man nor animal could live and man and animal
in turn minister to the life of tree and shrub
and leaf the flowers breathe fragrance and
unfold their beauty and blessing to the world
the sun sheds its light to gladden a
thousand worlds the ocean itself the
source of all our springs and fountains receives
the streams from every land but takes to give
the mists ascending from its bosom fall in showers
to water the earth that it may bring forth and bud
what is she saying everything has a purpose
and that purpose is to serve something else
are you following me all of creation
every blade of grass has a purpose and
that purpose is to serve something else
on this day the sabbath of god it reminds
us that there is no room for selfishness in
god's system can you say amen we are reminded
on this holy day that memorializes creation that
we are on this earth for someone else's benefit
not for yours and mine
look at the ten commandments of which the sabbath
is the chief the primary the pillar and ground
of the ten commandments is the sabbath
commandment that's where god's what
god's seal is found that's where he's identified
his territory identified and his title identified
it is the commandment that connects the one table
to the other table it is a commandment that the
devil has attacked with great success even among
seventh-day adventists i was in a certain country
and i was staying at the weekend with a preacher
a minister of the gospel seventh-day adventist
minister a faithful minister by the way
god bless him he told me face to face
in his conference they were trying
to make the ten commandments optional
keep them if you want he also told me his
conference circulated a memo to be signed
by all ministers who want to continue employment
in that conference do not quote ellen white from
the pulpit and i said okay tell me that again and
he repeated it he said i have the doctor i never
saw it he said i have the document and he refused
to sign he was called into the conference office
and they asked him why didn't you sign it
he knew that one of the conference officials was
on the board of the local witches association
yeah that was my reaction and he was named
on the website of the witches association
and so he said to the president why are you
harassing me for not signing a document that
dismisses ellen white when one of your
officials is a and he was just saying
uh go on home they left him alone i couldn't
believe it the ten commandments are optional
patriarchs and prophets page 49 paragraph one
ellen white writes god placed man under law
as an indispensable condition
of his very existence
let's look at that quotation god placed
man under law notice a wording as an
indispensable give me a synonym for
indispensable non-negotiable something else
can do without it something else something else
know what sister no change something else one more
all right the last thing is
related how about essential
god placed man under law as an indispensable
condition of his very existence now notice
the words his very existence not just
his life but even to exist as a corpse
is this existing yes or no come on answer me
does this exist is it under law who said no
is this under law yes are solids governed by
laws yes or no you chemists or whatever you are
are liquids governed by law
uh is air governed by law yes
all matter obeys law are you with
me the universe is made up of matter
the entire universe runs by law and god
made the universe and what day has he
given us to remind us of that today we must
remember we serve a god who functions by law
now the bible says christ is about ellen white
tells us oh you can deduce some scripture
god is above law yes but god's
entire kingdom is based on law
and so today we are celebrating a day that
reminds us there's a purpose for our lives
we celebrate a day that reminds us we are
accountable to someone you are not your final
boss the buck does not stop on your dressing
table it stops at god's throne room this day
reminds us that the commandments of god are truth
and they preserve life this day reminds us that
the word of god is all powerful it's divine and
the word that created is a word that creates today
this day also reminds us of something
else how much time do i have may i inquire
30 minutes all right listen to this quotation from
ellen white child guidance page 45 paragraph three
46 paragraph three in the natural world god
has placed in the hands of the children of men
the key to unlock the treasure house of his word
the visible the scene is illustrated by the unseen
the unseen story is illustrated by the scene
divine wisdom eternal truth infinite grace
are understood by the things that god has made
give me one word for that creation
verse 45 page 45 paragraph three says
the whole natural world is designed
to be an interpreter of the things of
god now evolution can never support
that because evolution does not have
intent and purpose and design it's random
things just happen not with god god is a designer
god has a purpose for everything and one of the
purposes for creation was that through observation
of creation we would learn about the creator
no wonder what was jesus's favorite
way of teaching give me one word
parables the kingdom of heaven which is
above is like what something on the earth
whether it's leaven or whatever it may
be the spiritual lesson drawn from the
physical does not the bible say go to the end
thou sluggard consider her ways and be wise
the bible seriously advises lazy people go and
spend some time at an ant's nest or a beehive
did not jesus say behold the fowls of the air they
saw not neither do they rape nor gather into barns
did he not say consider the lilies of the field
so we go from the ants to the birds to the lilies
and god knows what else because there are
lessons in the physical creation deliberately
built in are you with me all right let's go
to hebrews 11 let's read verse 3 our subject
the pillar and ground of truth hebrews 11 reading
verse 3. i thank god for the sabbath i really do
a lovely day snow or no snow
it looks beautiful from when you're in a building
looks very nice what book did i say what chapter
one verse through faith we understand that
the worlds were framed by the word of god
finish the verse so that things that were not
made of things which do appear in other words
the theologians have a term for that form they
call it uh creation ex nihilo out of nothing
all right there's a saying i think it
was by a fellow called antoine lavoisier
matter can neither be created nor destroyed
you scientists are probably familiar with that
now that is true as insofar as it applies to man
not to god god can create
matter and destroy matter
god has created matter and we
know god will destroy matter
when god created he created from nothing that's
the hallmark of creation to bring something into
existence that did not previous in other words god
did not need raw materials with which to create
what i mean by that is he did not need them
first someone did not have to supply god with
raw materials and then said now use this to
create god provides his own raw materials
so he creates out of nothing the bible
says if any man be in christ he's what
the correct translation is a new creation
now when a man or a woman is saved
are they created out of nothing
you see physical creation has a spiritual
parallel let's go to the bible and see what
evidence we can glean let's go to john 6
63. our subject the pill and ground of the
truth and for me that pill of that ground is
the sabbath commandment properly understood
john 6 63
this is jesus speaking are we ready read
with me it is the spirit that quickeneth
the flesh profiteth what nothing what
does that mean the flesh profiteth nothing
what does that mean to you
say that again the flesh is carnal
all right the flesh profiteth
nothing is anything good in the flesh
anything that is a value to god in the flesh no
go to john 3 4 6 listen to jesus again john 3 6.
you have that what does the bible say that which
is born of the flesh is flesh that which is born
of the spirit is spirit in order to enter
the kingdom you must be born of which one
spirit with how much of the
flesh none go to romans 7
verse 18 romans 7 reading verse 18 our subject
the pillar and ground of the truth bless you
do you have romans 7 verse 18 read
with me nice and loud what does it say
for i know that in me that is in my flesh
go on now dwelleth no good thing stop
now is there anything good in the flesh jesus says
the flesh prophet is what nothing he says flesh is
all flesh now go to galatians 5. i hope you don't
mind that i have you hitchhiking through the bible
galatians 5 we shall read from verse 19.
do you have that the bible says now the works of
the flesh are manifest which are these adultery
fornication uncleanness lasciviousness idolatry
witchcraft hatred variance emulations wrath strife
seditions heresies envyings murders drunkenness
revelings and what are the next few words
and such like meaning the list can go on and on
that's the works of the flesh how much of that is
pleasing to god none go to verse 22 but the fruit
of the spirit is love joy peace long-suffering
gentleness goodness faith meekness temperance
against such finish the verse there is no law
now put on your thinking caps well
i hope you never took them off
the bible says against such there is no
law now since god's kingdom is based on law
are you with me if there's no law against it
what can you conclude there's a law for it
which means the law of god is in perfect harmony
with love joy peace long suffering gentleness
goodness faith meekness temperance the ten
commandments harmonized perfectly in other
words obedience to god's law produces that by the
power of the holy spirit are you with me now the
works of the flesh nothing to do with god what am
i trying to show you there is nothing in a sinner
that the sinner can offer to god and
say start with this and make me a saint
are you with me we have no raw materials we
can give to god and tell god start with this
therefore salvation is also a work ex nihilo
just like physical creation out of nothing
so jesus told nicodemus
you've got to be born again
not improved a lot of improved
people on the way to hell
you don't believe me
when jesus spoke in matthew 24 and luke 17 and
he said as it was in the days of noah what did
he say they were doing committing did he say
robbing people did he say committing murder
did he say robbing banks stealing old ladies
social security check is that what he said
now surely those things were happening but he
did not mention those because it is too obvious
what's not obvious is that a decent
life can take you straight to hell
let me add a decent life where christ is not
the center and so what were they doing eating
drinking marrying given in marriage
and the days of lot they were eating
drink they eat they drank they bought they sold
they planted they build it running the businesses
running their families trying to get married
trying to have children trying to get one more
degree that's what they were doing being
upstanding citizens but god not the focus
what happened to them lost
so i'm saying to you there's nothing in
a person not even the most decent person
on earth that can be offered to god as a
piece of raw material with which to bring
about a transformed life and
so the sabbath is a reminder
not only of physical creation but of spiritual
creation god there's nothing i can offer god
it is all his work creating in me
placing in me you want to use that
expression he's righteous now i have how
much none he said the sabbath reminds me
that spiritually i am absolutely dependent
upon god for salvation for sanctification
does that mean i just fold my arms
until god pulled me up to heaven no
i must obey god but the power to obey
is not of me it is of god the sabbath
reminds us that it is god who writes his
law where on our hearts not in your spleen
but what does jesus say about the heart out of
the abundance of the heart the mouth speaketh a
good man matthew 12 35 out of the good treasure
of his heart bringing forth what good things and
an evil man out of the evil treasure bringeth
forth evil things now the only two things you
can do good or evil am i right for god shall bring
every work into judgment with every secret thing
whether it be good or evil ecclesiastes 12 14. so
jesus says the heart produces either good or evil
god puts the law right where all that we do and we
are emerge the heart his law his commands now if
god puts his commands in your heart and everything
you do comes out of the heart what does god expect
listen to me carefully you're about
to flunk listen to me carefully
if god put his commandments in
your heart and he puts nothing else
what does he expect out of that heart obedience
but notice who puts it because you cannot put it
and i cannot put it let me add to that not only
am i unable to put it i don't want to put it
and so it's all god in that sense it's all god he
puts it and with our permission he keeps it there
the sabbath is a reminder that we are saved
ex nihilo there is nothing we can offer
god on the basis of this let me in nothing
and so the sabbath humbles us without god all
we are are golden caskets lovely on the outside
what's on the inside dead men's bones does not
the bible say in first timothy chapter 5 verse
6 she that liveth in pleasure is dead while she
liveth without the life of christ in us we are
dead ephesians 2 1 you hath he come on you hath
he quickened who were dead in trespasses and sins
let's recite the fourth commandment don't look
recite are you ready i want the men to do it first
men do you mind standing stand
up men men athletic men stand up
let's recite the fourth
commandment you heard elder
boar's presentation last night about male headship
the night before we probably speak again today
male headship is a serious business i don't
want to talk about elderboro's subject
i read a piece of research years ago if the
first person in the family to accept christ
is a child there's a 14 chance the whole family
will follow and i just can't put my hand on it
again if this first person in a family to accept
christ is the man the father there's the mother
there's a 23 chance the whole family will follow
hold on to your seats if the first person in the
family to accept christ is the father there's
a 96 chance the whole family will follow
do you think it's by accident most people in
prison are men the devil seeks to destroy it
destruction begins when you interfere
with god's order are you following me
it may take hundreds of years but it's
happening and so i love to see men in church
i love men and that's a
spiritual statement don't go
are you with me i love men come on say amen i
love to see many church men fourth commandment
remember the sabbath day to keep it holy
six days shalt thou labor and dwarf thy word
but the seventh day is the sabbath of the
lord thy god in it thou shalt not do any work
thou not thy son nor thy daughter thy man's
servant nor thy maidservant nor thy cattle
nor thy stranger that is within thy gates for
in six days the lord made heaven and earth
the sea and all that in them is and rested the
seventh day wherefore the lord blessed the sabbath
day and sanctified it say amen for god men you
sit ladies you can stay seated on your thrones
you look like queens and princesses ladies
your turn where would i be without my mother
i uh god bless my mother she's 94 lives
in berian springs wears high heels
i'm not joking i said mom why are you wearing
and keeps a garden takes care of herself and she
always told us his children there are two things
she always prayed for one lord keep me alive
long enough until my children are all adults
so no one has to take care of them and she
never worked until her youngest child was 23.
she said i don't want to be at work
wondering what is being done to my children
so i thank god my mother lived her life for
her children and the other prayer request
she had was when i cannot take care of myself
father take me and so i god bless her i mean
that from my heart god bless my mother god bless
all the mothers mothers to be potential mothers
but ladies let's uh recite the fourth
commandment remember the sabbath day
keep it holy six days shalt thou labor
and do all thy work but the seventh day
blessed us let the church say amen
the pillar and ground of the truth ella white was
taken up to heaven her escort was jesus jesus took
him to the most holy place he opened the curtain
she walked in she saw the ark jesus lifted the
lid and she saw the ten commandments you can read
in the early writings all ten commandments had a
light the fourth commandment had the brightest
light not only that it had a halo around it
my brothers and sisters the commandment
the sabbath commandment will be the test
in the last days are you with me it was the
test for the israelites coming out of egypt
you listen to exodus 16 verse 4 then the lord
said unto moses behold i will rent bread from
heaven for you and the people shall go out and
gather a certain way every day that i may prove
them whether they will walk in my law or not
it is the test commandment meaning if someone
genuinely keeps the sabbath that person will
have no problem with the other commandments and
all god's commandments are truth the commandments
preserve life the commandments themselves are life
because god's word is life are you with me and
the commandments are part of god's word so the
commandments are life when you receive them into
your heart at the pudding of christ you receive
life and so we say the lord's prayer together our
father which art in heaven hallowed be thy name
thy kingdom come thy will be done that's the law
on earth how as it is in heaven because the same
commandments you're required to observe the
angels observe let's not see that as a burden
let us see that as god thinking so much of us
that what he requires of angels he requires of us
it does not lower the angels it elevates us can
you say a man those of you who have children in
school you want them to bring home report
cards not with c's and d's and e's and f's
you want to see what ace because a is for
adventists can you say amen and so god has high
standards for us and the highest standard is the
character of jesus christ as reflected in his law
how many of us will say father come into my heart
give me your spirit that i may live by your law
can i see your right hand heads bowed eyes closed
father in heaven we thank you for the pill and
ground of truth we thank you all your commandments
of truth we thank you the lord is the truth
we thank you the works of your hands are done in
truth we thank you your laws and laws of life ah
god in heaven change our taste buds change
our desires give us a love for obedience
that only comes when jesus dwells in the
heart so that we may say as our savior said
i delight to do thy will o my god ye thy lord is
within my heart bless your men your women your
sons and daughters bless the speakers to come from
this point forward when we leave this place they
god let us leave walking on spiritual air closer
to you more determined to save you come what may
we offer this prayer in jesus name let
god's obedient people say amen and amen